في كل بقعه من بقاع جازان في السعوديه
تمتد رائحه الفل الجزائري الذي يعد احد
اشهر النباتات العطريه في المنطقه مع
بدايه موسم الحصاد في اول فصل الشتاء تكثر
انواع الفل المباع في السوق والذي يشكل
زينه لابناء المنطقه
مزارع الفل الجازاني تمتاز بوجود الكثير
المحاصيل ومنتجات الفن الفل والنباتات
العطريه في الزيوت والمعطرات والماء
العطري لاسيما في مناطق عده اليوم من هناك
سنتعرف اكثر على هذه الزراعه التي اصبحت
احد اكثر مواسم شهره واجملها على الاطلاق
عديده هي انواع الفل الذي يزرع في منطقه
جازان في المملكه العربيه السعوديه ومنها
الفل العزاني يتميز بحباته الكبيره ولونه
الاصفر يتم نظمه مثل سلاسل طويله تتراس
حباته جنبا الى جنب باتساق جميل ليستخدم
في الزنا اما الفول العريشي فهو شديد
البياض والعضق حجمه كبير يتميز بيتفتح
حباته خلال فتره الليل فضلا عن رائحته غير
العاديه في قوتها وسحرها ايضا هناك الفل
البلدي هو مائل للاصفرار وليس لحباتته
بحجم ولو ثابت وكذلك حباته متباينه
ومختلفه في العاده
الجازاني يزرع في منطقه همم في تلك
المنطقه بكثره ويتميز برائته واريته
المختلف يستخدم بكثره في المناسبات
والافراح
الجاهليه
[موسيقى]
على كل المزيد ينضم الينا من جازان سمير
وسام القاسم صباح العربيه صباح الجمال يا
اسامه يسعد صباحك عرفنا على اكثر محاصيل
جزاء جمالا وشهره تفضل
اهلا وسهلا نادين وسهام تحيه طيبه لكم
مولد جميع مشاهدين صباح العربيه اولا
الساعه تشير الى التاسعه فل هنا في جازان
وثانيا على انغام الموسيقى والاغاني
الشعبيه لابد ان تكون حراسه كل ايضا مع
الافراح والمناسبات
صباح الفل على السيره
صباح الفل واقعيه ااا هنيئا لك يا سهام
بميلادك حابين نهديك اليوم كبش فل هنا من
اشهر مزارع الفل في في جازان سبحان الله
جت الفرحه على الفرحه طبعا احنا بنتكلم
اليوم عن الفل
بنتكلم اليوم عن الفل اللي هو يعتبر اشهر
نبات عطري هنا في جازان جنوب غربيه
السعوديه تتكلم عن رائحه تتكلم عن المنظر
تتكلم عن الارتباطها الكبير جدا
بالمناسبات والافراح لا تخلو اي مناسبه
هنا في جازان من الفل طبعا اللي البسه
الحين هو الكبش وهذا الكبش يعتبر عقد فل
بلدي من هنا وهو فل عريشي في التاكيد طبعا
ليش انا اليوم قاعد اتكلم بجانب سله الورد
وبجانب الجعاده بدي احكي اول شيء عن سله
الورد هذا الفل اللي بدنا نحكي عنه اليوم
وهذا البعثران وهذا الشام وهذا النرجس
وهذا الكافي هذه النباتات العطريه هي
الاشهر في جازان في كل محافظاتها ومرتبطه
بشكل كبير جدا بالافراح والمناسبات حتى
الرجال النساء يلبسونها على راسهم
ويضعونها في ملابسهم في كل في كل مناسبه
هذه الجعاده يا نادين وسهام هي القعاده
التي كانت تزف عليها العروس انجازانيه وسط
هذه نباتات العطريه يعني نقول انه احنا
اليوم بعرس مصغر بس بدون عروسه وهذه ايضا
احدى التشكيلات الخاصه بالفل نحكي اليوم
ايضا عن انتاج الفول هنا في جازان جازان
تحوي اكثر من 950 مزرعه يصل النتائجها الى
اكثر من 300 طن سنويا من الفل البلدي طبعا
موسم الصيف هو اكثر مواسم الفل النتائج
لكن ايضا فصل الشتاء بسبب عذوبه الجو
وبروده الاجواء تكون رائحه الجو ايضا مع
رائحه الفل يعني ما بدي اكون مبالغ كثير
بس ان انت بتحكي عن المناطق اللي هنا جنب
ال- همم جنب المزارع بتشمه كثير رائحه
الفل مع الهواء العذب مع الهواء البارد
نواحي المزرعه كلها رايحه فل يعني حديث
سكن كثير جميله
حساسه وبتزعل من صاحبها اذا ما بدل لها
بالطريقه الحلوه
تاكدت من هالمعلومه
والله حساسه بشكل ما تتصوري يعني لدرجه
انه اليوم الواحد
بشكل جيد على مستوى ال100 وعلى المستوى
التربه عن مستوى ايضا القطف في الوقت
المناسب يمكن ان تتدرج شجره الفول يعني
شجره الفل تقريبا هي من اكثر الاشجار
الحساسه هنا في جازان ذلك نتكلم عن 950
مزرعه قليله جدا ليش قليله لانها لابد ان
تكون عنايتها اعلى وبالتالي تكون تكلفتها
ايضا اعلى هذه الشجره مثلا
تحتاج الى اكثر من ثلاث سنوات الى ان ان
تنتج طبعا هذا الفول هذه نبات نبته الفل
اللي الان امامكم على الهواء هذه النبته
هي التي تم بها تشكيله العقود يتم بها
ايضا تشكيل الورود والازهار هنا في جازان
هذه المزرعه من احدى اكبر المزارع هنا في
جازان جنوب غربيه السعوديه تقع في ابو
عريش واكثر المحافظات الانتاج الانتاجيه
للفل هي محافظه ابو عريش همم
ابو عريش ابو عريش مثنى كله وصبيا مفن كله
يعني درستهم يعني مرتبطين بالافراح بشكل
كبير جدا انا اليوم صراحه خاطري اهديكم
هذه الباغه لانها لو جاتكم استديو بتقعد
اسبوع كامل ما شاء الله حالها ايضا هنا
اهل المنطقه لم يكتفوا فقط بانتاج وزراعه
الفل بل وصلوا الى ان ينتجوا معطل كامل او
حتى مخلط من الفل هذا المخلط نادر جدا
يعني نادين وسهام وغالي
[ضحك]
بدنا اياكم تونا المزرعه اساسا بدنا
تحضروا هنا المزرعه ونستقبلكم ونعطيكم
الورد والفل والمخلط وكل شيء ونحتفل
بسهامه ايضا تسلم يا اسامه ايام كلها
سعاده يا رب شكرا لك